uns erreicht aber noch nie in diesen
augenblicken eine breaking news
staatsschützer der brandenburger polizei
haben in diesen stunden die wohnung des
veganen kochs attila hildmann in
brandenburg durchsucht der sich selbst
ultra rechts und einen verschwörungs
prediger nennt die durchsuchung sei zum
zweck der gefahrenabwehr auf antrag der
staatsanwaltschaft cottbus vom
amtsgericht bernau angeordnet worden
bestätigte der sprecher
und in seinen nachrichtenkanal bei
telegramm ja da bestätigte attila
hildmann den polizeieinsatz bei der
staatsanwaltschaft in cottbus laufen
nach angaben des polizeisprechers
mehrere ermittlungsverfahren gegen hält
man unter anderem wegen des verdachts
der volksverhetzung
dazu in den nächsten minuten mehr bei
bild.de
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren